[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA TARONAS: It is a common misconception
that the builders of the pyramids were slaves forced to work by the King.
However, these workers were, for the most part, skilled builders
and craftsmen in the permanent service of the King.
The specific numbers of the workforce needed
for the building of such monuments is difficult to precisely identify.
What we do know is that these men were divided
into crews of peasant conscripts of about 2,000 men.
The crews were divided into two gangs, which in turn were divided into 5
groups called 'saa' of 200 men.
These groups were themselves divided into 10 divisions of 20 men
or maybe 20 divisions of 10 men.
The different gangs had names, which usually
included that of the reigning king, such as Friends of Khufu and the Drunkards
of Menkaure.
These different gangs had different tasks
within the construction of the pyramid.
Thanks to expeditions carried out throughout the 20th century,
we have access to the skeletal remains of some of the pyramid builders.
And these have been analyzed in bio archaeological studies.
To be able to further gauge how the health of the pyramid builders
compare to other people living at Giza contemporaneously,
various indicators of health have been compared from these two populations--
coming from the Western cemetery for high officials
and the southeast cemetery for workers.
The evidence shows that the pyramid workers died earlier in life
than their more privileged counterparts, who were also living at Giza.
Men died nearly 10 years earlier and women died roughly five years sooner.
The female workers from Giza, however, exhibit a smaller stature
than their Amarna counterparts, standing at 150.53 centimeters,
while the Amarna women were roughly 154.02 centimeters.
The laborers at Giza display severe changes to their vertebral bodies,
the largest part of an individual vertebra,
which indicates that they experienced fairly high levels of spinal trauma.
Recent evidence from the Giza Plateau suggest
that, at least in the case of Khafre and Menkaure,
the workmen were living in permanent settlements that
actually represent some of the earliest known urban planning.
In these workmen's villages we find abundant remains
of high quality animals, such as cattle and sheep and goats,
which were not normally part of the daily diet of the commoners.
In addition, the remains of two bakeries and one hospital
were recovered, again, pointing to the high quality treatment
that these workers received.